[Musik]
von den Pagoden Myanmars zu den
Hochhäusern Singapurs von den ehemaligen
Schlachtfeldern Kambodschas ins
pulsierende Jakarta
640 Millionen Menschen darunter Muslime
Christen Buddhisten Taoisten und
konfuzionisten Thailand Malaysia die
Philippinen und Vietnam Asien gehört zu
den komplexesten Regionen der Welt
es ist unglaublich vielfältig bietet so
viel Potenzial für Handel und
Verbundenheit
die Wirtschaft von Asien ist insgesamt
so groß wie die Indiens die Chancen sind
gewaltig ebenso jedoch die
Herausforderungen
Grenzen verlieren gerade in dieser
Region an Bedeutung
Südostasien steht am Scheideweg
eine aufstrebende Wirtschaftsmacht der
in Zukunft von wichtigen Entscheidungen
abhängt die die gesamte nächste
Generation in prägen werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo ich bin Hess Linder Armin unsere
Reise beginnt in Thailand wo Asien vor
über 50 Jahren entstand
fünf Länder die sich zum Schutz vor dem
kommunistischen China Verbündeten
seitdem hat sich viel geändert
Vietnam Myanmar und Kambodscha sind in
schwierigen Zeiten beigetreten
die Wirtschaftsleistung der Region
wächst seit zehn Jahren jedes Jahr um
fünf Prozent
die größte Errungenschaft war es die
vielfältigste Region des Planeten zu
vereinen
640 Millionen Menschen darunter Muslime
Christen Buddhisten Taoisten und
konfuzionisten
Frieden und Wohlstand zu erwirken
wirkten nirgends unwahrscheinlicher als
hier
[Musik]
wir sind weit gekommen darum bleibe ich
optimistisch die Schwarzmaler sagen
natürlich es gehe nichts voran oder
nicht weit genug aber wenn man sich eher
Asia den Personen und Güterverkehr sowie
den Handel innerhalb von Asien ansieht
sieht man große Fortschritte
darum bin ich sehr optimistisch
die Finanzbranche ist nicht in allen
Ländern gleich ausgereift es
unterscheidet sich den Rahmenbedingungen
entsprechend
für grenzübergreifende finanzintegration
werden wir wohl einiges standardisieren
müssen
wir müssen nicht alle auf den gleichen
Standard kommen aber die Standards der
Länder müssen für grenzüberschreitende
Geschäfte miteinander kompatibel sein
das ist das Goldene Dreieck ich bin in
Thailand das ist Myanmar und dort ist
Laos unter uns der mächtige Mekong der
bis nach Vietnam fließt diese Region
bekannt für den opium-handel ist nur ein
kleines Puzzleteil von Asien
die zehn Mitgliedstaaten unterscheiden
sich drastisch
von Indonesien mit der größten
muslimischen Bevölkerung der Welt bis
zum kleinen Brunei die politische und
religiöse Vielfalt ist gewaltig die 640
Millionen Bewohner von Asien Stellen 9
Prozent der Weltbevölkerung
die Wirtschaftsleistung von 2,8
Billionen Dollar ist ebenso groß wie die
von Frankreich Großbritannien oder
Indien
[Musik]
es gibt hier sehr reiche Länder die
Singapur und Brunei and you have aber
auch arme Länder wie Laos und Kambodscha
sie
in derselben Organisation an große
Länder wie Indonesien mit 270 Millionen
Einwohnern und Singapur mit 5 Millionen
somit ergänzen sich die Länder von Asien
aufgrund der Kosten durch Zelle und der
Transportgeschwindigkeit ist die
Vereinigung noch nicht abgeschlossen
sonst werden China und Indien den
Online-Handel und die Handelswege
dominieren
scheint es manchmal die Länder Asiens
würden mehr miteinander konkurrieren als
kooperieren
die Frage stellt sich durchaus und sie
ist zu bejahen
man sieht das auch in China dort
konkurrieren die Provinzen manchmal
untereinander bei Asian findet es auf
nationaler Ebene statt und ist daher
noch intensiver
ein Meilenstein der starken Gruppe war
2015 die Einrichtung der Asian
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft AEC die
ist ein einheitlicher Markt der sich in
die Weltwirtschaft einfügt
für den Warenhandel ist es quasi ein
einziger Markt
es gibt aber noch finanzielle Hürden die
wir überwinden müssen
ich arbeite seit über 20 Jahren in der
Easy und den Verhandlungen dieses
Abkommens
wenn ich mir die Errungenschaften aus
diesen 20 Jahren ansehe bin ich doch
sehr zufrieden damit
der Unterschied ist die Sichtweise ist
das Glas halb leer oder halb voll ich
würde sagen im Vergleich zu unserem
Ausgangspunkt ist deshalb voll
ich hätte gerne einen einheitlichen
Markt und Bewegungsfreiheit für
Arbeitskräfte was für zehn Jahre
vielleicht etwas zu viel verlangt ist
wenn wir aber den einheitlichen Markt
haben warum sollte nicht eher Asia 100%
aller Airlines in Asien besitzen
Asien Asien sollte seinen Bürgern auf
vielerlei artnutzen
finanzintegration
Wirtschaftsintegration
handelsintegration
das Ziel ist eine einheitliche Politik
wirtschaftlicher Nachhaltigkeit
in dieser Region an Bedeutung
zu dieser Jahreszeit sind weite Gebiete
im Norden Thailands Myanmar und Laos von
Rauch verhüllt
Landwirte brenne nach der Ernte ihre
Felder ab der Ertrag wird in kleinen
Betrieben wie diesem verpackt
Kleinunternehmen den Anschluss zu
vierten industriellen Revolution zu
ermöglichen ist eine der größten
Herausforderungen von Asien die Kosten
von Finanzdienstleistungen sinken durch
fintech und allgemeine Technologie
drastisch
nicht nur können wir viel mehr Menschen
Bankdienstleistungen und Versicherungen
ermöglichen sondern auch Menschen in
entlegenen Gebieten
darum sind Smartphones so wichtig denn
sie verändern unsere
Finanzdienstleistungen grundlegend
das ist das geniale an Asian Asian ist
Asian ist die unvollkommendste
Organisation der Welt wenn man bei genau
hinsieht machen wir zwei Schritte nach
vorn einen zurück und einen zur Seite
wie eine Krabbe die im Kreis läuft über
Jahrzehnte beobachtet wird Asien aber
immer stärker und stärker ein Grund ist
die Flexibilität von Asien unser
Konsensprinzip leistet uns gute Dienste
denn es ist sehr flexibel
es ist unvorstellbar dass 440 Millionen
Menschen in Asien keine Bankkonten haben
das ist unser nächstes Thema bei Asian
the next generation
willkommen zurück in Südostasien gibt es
viele kleine Unternehmen wie diese in
manchen Ländern stellen sie 90 Prozent
aller Arbeitsplätze
gewaltige 440 Millionen Menschen kein
Bankkonto
das sind mehr Menschen als die
Bevölkerung der USA und Deutschlands
zusammen
man will die bankenlose Bevölkerung
erschließen doch bisher ist das
schwierig da oft nur die Menschen mit
schlechten bankzugang erreicht werden
warum
es geht um verschiedene Dinge wenn es
darum geht die bankenlose oder
unterversorgte Bevölkerung zu erreichen
muss es klare Richtlinien für die Arten
von Produkten und Bereichen geben die
wir bewerben möchten
in Thailand ist die
Haushaltsverschuldung hoch und manche
Teile der Bevölkerung sind ebenfalls
hoch verschuldet
darum brauchen wir fintech und
verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit Krediten
um bessere Versorgung zu vernünftigen
Preisen zu gewährleisten
mit neuen Technologien die nicht mehr
Probleme für sie erschaffen und ihre
finanzielle Lage weiter die
stabilisieren
ich halte die Kreditwürdigkeit und
garantieprogramme von Ratingagenturen
für eine mögliche Lösung
wie wir Kleinunternehmer unterstützen
und ihnen den Zugang zu
Finanzdienstleistungen ermöglichen
können
die SMI interessant gleichzeitig halte
ich digitale Finanzlösungen auch für
eine Möglichkeit für Kleinunternehmer am
Finanzwesen teilzunehmen da die
Informationen hierbei genauer sind und
sie so Zugang gehalten könnten bitte
Information equisits oder
Richy Access different die finanzielle
inklusion ist nicht in allen Ländern
gleich weit fortgeschritten vor Thailand
in Thailand entspricht die Schwierigkeit
ein Girokonto zu bekommen in etwa
normalen Standards
bei Auslandsüberweisungen haben wir
sorgen
die Gebühren für Auslandsüberweisungen
nach und aus Thailand sind mit die
höchsten der Welt
das wollen wir ändern und fintech und
andere neue Technologien können uns
dabei helfen mehr und mehr Menschen am
Markt teilhaben zu lassen
für Händler in Myanmar und Reisbauern in
Kambodscha im Geschäft in Hanoi Manila
und Jakarta und Bangkok eröffnet fintech
eine völlig neue Welt
doch geht es dabei immer wieder um die
gleichen Kernthemen Nachhaltigkeit
Vernetzung und Inklusion wie stellen Sie
sicher dass Länder wie Kambodscha und
Vietnam nicht abgehängt werden
zuallererst vietnam hat wirklich große
Fortschritte gemacht
begann bekamen Kambodscha Laos und
Myanmar die Finanzierungshilfen für
Infrastrukturprojekte zu günstigeren
Konditionen
wir brauchen derartige praktische
Initiativen
auch die Ausbildung und Umschulung die
gesamte Berufsbildung wird so gefördert
Training so das sind alles praktische
Maßnahmen
auch dass die kostenstrukturell in
diesen Ländern geringer sind als in
anderen Asian Staaten zieht seinerseits
Investoren
Anja begrüßte die Digitalisierung mit
offenen Armen ist der Rest der Region
ebenfalls bereit für die vierte
industrielle Revolution
wir sind etwas im Rückstand aber wir
holen auf
mit der einzigartigen tech-branche von
Indonesien
der Verwendung von Weiber in den
Philippinen Bruder von line in Thailand
und dem wachsenden Onlinehandel sowie
der wachsenden Vernetzung durch
Mobiltelefone und Apps liegen wir nicht
mehr weit zurück
ich sage immer man muss groß denken
Asian muss in der Technologiewelt groß
denken
unser Rückstand ist nicht groß die
Bildung muss noch aufholen und wir
müssen die Menschen hier ausbilden um
unser Humankapital richtig zu nutzen
ich glaube Asian wird sich sehr schnell
anpassen sobald sich eine Gelegenheit
dazu ergibt
ich denke wir können ein paar Plätze
gutmachen wenn wir uns in einigen
Bereichen anpassen
[Musik]
die Integration benachbar
phantasial-länder ist ein wichtiger
Schritt der 2015 durch die ayc möglich
wurde
dadurch erhöhte sich das Wachstum des
Bruttoinlandprodukts erheblich er stieg
von 1.200 Dollar pro Einwohner vor 20
Jahren auf fast 4.300 Dollar
das ist für die finanzielle Integration
sehr wichtig
wie schwierig wird die finanzintegration
dadurch dass sich die Mitgliedsstaaten
in Sachen Entwicklung so drastisch
unterscheiden
dadurch dass sie auf unterschiedlichen
Entwicklungsstufen stehen ergänzen die
Staaten einander einige Staaten wie
Singapur Malaysia und Thailand
erwirtschaften Überschüsse während
andere Länder Geld brauchen
so können wir einander unterstützen und
ergänzen
[Musik]
fintech kann die Produktivität aller
asien-staaten verbessern
Finanzsysteme in Asien sind stark
verbesserungsfähig und Technologie kann
hier eine große Rolle spielen
die finanzielle Inklusion verbessern da
die Kosten für Finanzdienstleistungen
drastisch sinken werden
so zehn Länder mit eigenen Kulturen
Sprachen und Religionen alle auf anderen
Entwicklungsstufen
gibt es dennoch eine gemeinsame
asia-identität
das werden wir als nächstes herausfinden
[Musik]
in den ersten 50 Jahren ging es beim
Projekt Asien vornehmlich um die
Verständigung der Regierungen und ihre
Zusammenarbeit jetzt geht es darum den
Menschen von Asien ein Gefühl der
Zugehörigkeit zu vermitteln es freut
mich dass Asien hier die Europäische
Union nachahmt wie man in Europa eine
eu-fahne sieht sieht man hier ebenso die
Landesfahne und daneben die Fahne von
Asien
gibt es denn eine asia-identität in der
Frage herrscht wohl keine Einigkeit ich
glaube nicht dass es so etwas gibt und
ich bin überzeugt da asianist warum
nicht
es geht darum was Asia an seinen
einfachen Bürgern bedeutet
wir müssen stärker an unserer Marke
Arbeiten zeigen das Asian jeden
einzelnen etwas angeht es wird wohl oft
eher als Bedrohung denn als Chance
wahrgenommen
in Bezug auf die asia-identität wird
viel unternommen gerade im
soziokulturellen Bereich das ergänzt
sich mit der finanziellen und
wirtschaftlichen Integration
man
es trade mit wachsendem Handel und
zunehmendem Tourismus wird sich das
wechselseitige Verständnis und die
Wertschätzung innerhalb der asiengruppe
stark verbessern
Kunden gibt es eine asia-identität
in vielerlei Hinsicht ja wir mögen über
600 Millionen Menschen sein mit
verschiedenen Sprachen Kulturen und
Identitäten aber andererseits sind wir
gleichzeitig auch alle ein sehr
gelassenes Volk
das ist ein Vorteil durch den wir besser
zusammenarbeiten können
es geht aber nicht nur um Identität
sondern auch Mobilität sie ist eine der
größten Herausforderungen in Asien
Arbeit waren und Geld müssen schließen
über diese Grenze kommen die Menschen
aus Myanmar jeden Tag nach Thailand um
zu arbeiten und zu handeln aber in Asien
Stellen Grenzen oft auch Hindernisse für
Geschäftsbeziehungen da
[Musik]
in Thailand gibt es über 3 Millionen
Gastarbeiter aus Myanmar ihr Geld nach
Myanmar zu schicken ist für sie sehr
teuer an der Grenze wird oft den
Naturalien gehandelt weil es so teuer
ist Geld über die Grenze hinweg in
andere Länder zu senden und zu empfangen
die finanzielle Inklusion deutlich zu
verbessern
Grenzen sind für Arbeiter ein großes
Problem wie können wir das Problem lösen
und standardisieren
das ist ein heikles Thema denn der freie
Fluss von Arbeitskraft steht letztlich
nicht zur Debatte
nicht alle sind gleichermaßen bereit
Menschen mit bestimmten Qualifikationen
und Angehörigen bestimmter Berufe diese
Mobilität zu gewähren
daran arbeiten wir die Arbeitsmärkte
sind in ganz Asien auf verschiedenen
Entwicklungsstufen
wir müssen uns daher darauf
konzentrieren die verschiedenen
Ökonomien zu integrieren durch den
Handel mit Waren sowie Dienstleistungen
und durch Investitionen
wenn wir in verschiedenen Teilen von
Asien Wachstum schaffen können können
die Menschen in allen Ländern
angemessene gute Arbeit haben
auf der anderen Seite müssen wir mit den
Zentralbanken zusammenarbeiten wobei wir
gute Fortschritte bei der Nutzung
lokaler Währungen für Handel und
Investitionen sehen konnten
vor zwei Jahren begannen die Bank of
Highland und die Bank negerammalasia die
Nutzung von niederländischen Bad und
malaysischen Ring geht für Handel und
Investitionen zu fördern
seit letztem Jahr ist die Zentralbank
von Indonesien als dritter Partner dabei
dadurch nähern sich die Wechselkurse der
Währungen einander an somit haben
Unternehmen in der Region eine echte
Wahl und die Wechselkurse und Gebühren
sinken
in verschiedenen Teilen von Asien sieht
die Zukunft teils sehr anders aus
für die großen Unternehmen und großen
Städte geht es nicht nur um den
Austausch über asiengrenzen hinweg
sondern um den globalen Markt
zig Millionen kleiner bis mittlerer
Unternehmen benötigen generell Zugang zu
Märkten
Arbeiter suchen Arbeit wo sie können
Eltern suchen Bildung für ihre Kinder
das ist ein Grund warum Asian eine der
vielfältigsten und komplexesten Regionen
der Welt ist
was ist ihre Vision für Asien
wir hoffen dass Asien weiter Sicherheit
Wohlstand und Zufriedenheit bietet
prospress and please and das wir weiter
jede Woche das Wohlergehen der Menschen
in Asien verbessern können
die ganze Arbeit für die wirtschaftliche
und finanzielle Integration die
Förderung von fintech und dergleichen
alles dient letztlich dem Ziel das
Wohlergehen der Menschen in Asien zu
verbessern
so wollen wir Frieden und Stabilität in
Asien waren und zufrieden und Wohlstand
auf der Welt beitragen
wir sollten beachten was wir im Westen
beobachten können in Asien
wenn der Ruhestand in Asien steigt
werden auch Nachfrage und Vielfalt
weiter wachsen
dadurch könnte sich die Gesellschaft
Spalten und soziale Aspekte wie die
wohlstandsverwaltung ein immer
wichtigeres Thema werden
rasieren sollte sich bewusst werden was
unsere Stärken und was unsere Schwächen
sind
einige Länder haben offensichtliche
Spezialisierungen die sich von anderen
Ländern unterscheiden Singapur wird nie
eine große agrarnation aber es hat eine
sehr starke Finanzinfrastruktur
die Länder sollten also nicht
zwangsläufig andere imitieren sondern
ihre eigenen Nische finden
mehr es gibt gemeinsame Probleme die wir
bewältigen müssen und Technologie wird
die Grenzen zwischen den Ländern
verschwimmen lassen
es geht also darum dass alle profitieren
und dass wir mit dem
integrationsnetzwerk von Asian Wachstum
und nachhaltigen Wohlstand für alle
Bürger in Asien fördern
sollte vorsichtiger und pragmatischer
vorgehen
die arbeiterströme lenken
wenn ich mich nicht irre arbeiten
bereits Millionen Indonesia in Malaysia
in Singapur Arbeiten 1,7 Millionen
Ausländer in diesem Stadtstaat auf einer
Insel
in Thailand gibt es viele Gastarbeiter
aus Myanmar so
Arbeitskräfte sind ständig im Fluss aber
eine echte Bewegungsfreiheit wie in der
Europäischen Union ist nirgendwo in
Sicht
mein Traum für Asien wäre ein
fortwährender Zusammenhalt dass wir
nicht aufgrund der wachsenden Rivalität
zwischen den USA und China zerbrechen
die Sorge wie Asia an diesem gewaltigen
Wettstreit zwischen den USA und China in
den kommenden 10 20 Jahren überstehen
kann bereitet mir schlaflose Nächte
von der Quelle bis zum Meer liegt der
Mekong mehr als 4000 Kilometer zurück
und ist seit Jahrhunderten die Verb
spannende Lebensader in diesem Teil der
Welt der Wandel ist jedoch nicht
aufzuhalten gewaltige
Infrastrukturprojekte und die digitale
Revolution erschaffen eine völlig neue
Zukunft
[Musik]
640 Millionen Menschen eine
Wirtschaftsleistung vergleichbar mit
Indien Asien ist eine emporstrebende
Wirtschaftsmacht in ihrer Mitte liegt
ein wachstumsgigant
Indonesien
wir sind noch im Rückstand aber
gemeinsam mit Indien sind wir die
größten Volkswirtschaften hier unser
Fortschritt wird globale Folgen haben
17.000 Inseln beherbergen die größte
muslimische Bevölkerung der Welt
Vernetzung und Inklusion stehen im
Vordergrund
Indonesien zeigt im kleinen was Asian
ohne Grenzen sein könnte
Indonesien muss die Führung übernehmen
um Asien zu stärken und wirklich in den
Mittelpunkt zu rücken
in Indonesien buchte Online-Handel und
der Präsident plant 100 Millionen
Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen um den
nächsten Generation in Asien den Weg zu
bereiten
willkommen in Jakarta der Hauptstadt
indones einem Land mit 270 Millionen
Einwohnern an der Außengrenze von Asien
die Wirtschaftsleistung macht ein
Drittel des gesamten Bundes aus bis 2050
könnte Indonesien die viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt werden
[Musik]
Indonesien hatte von Beginn an eine
Führungsrolle in Asien
neutrale Rolle einnehmen damit die
Nachbarn sich nicht bedroht fühlen
[Musik]
in den kommenden fünf bis zehn Jahren
muss Indonesien aber wohl eine stärkere
Führungsrolle in Asien einnehmen
und sich als globales Zentrum behaupten
kann
[Musik]
das ehrgeizige Ziel die finanzielle
Inklusion auszuweiten
es gibt ein Programm für die Vermittlung
finanzieller Mündigkeit
werden das digitale Bankwesen und die
relevanten Teile des Finanzwesens mit
Hilfe der digitalen Marktwirtschaft
ausgebaut
es schreitet schnell voran und
Technologie wird wohl die Lösung für
Inklusion und Mündigkeit sein
Inklusion Bildung und Kompetenz werden
die entscheidenden Bausteine sein
Vernetzung war hier schon immer
schwierig
doch die Digitalisierung schreitet den
Indonesien mit am schnellsten voran
Ende der erfahren sind digitale
Technologie und digitale
Telekommunikation finden immer mehr
Verwendung
das können wir nutzen um den Wohlstand
und die Wirtschaft noch weiter
auszubauen und zu verstärken
darum beschleunigen wir die Entwicklung
von Zahlungssystemen fintech und
Online-Handel um die finanzielle
Inklusion zu fördern
wir sehen darin auch eine großartige
Chance für viele Kleinunternehmen und
Menschen ohne Bankkonto
Indonesien verstehen will muss die
Abgeschiedenheit begreifen die
Ausdehnung des Archipels entspricht der
Strecke von New York nach Alaska das
Land will in den kommenden fünf Jahren
350 Milliarden Dollar in Straßen Brücken
und Kraftwerke investieren um zumindest
einen Teil der 17.000 Inseln zu
verbinden
Präsident djokovido hat bereits
beachtliche Fortschritte erzielt
in seiner ersten Amtszeit wurden mit
ähnlich hohen Investitionen Straßen im
ganzen Land erbaut
das Nahverkehrssystem Jakarta gilt als
Symbol für dieses Vorhaben
die Hauptstadt hat nun auch einen neuen
Flughafen und günstige Airlines die die
großen Städte miteinander verbinden die
einzige billionenschwere Volkswirtschaft
von Asien wächst jedes Jahr um etwa fünf
Prozent
es geht nicht nur um physische
Verbindung sondern auch um die vielen
Probleme bei Datenströmen Zahlungen
Besteuerung und auch Datenschutz und
Sicherheit
und um Fachkräfte
wenn wir die vierte Freiheit die
Bewegungsfreiheit der Arbeiter erreichen
und uns auf die Digitalisierung
konzentrieren könnten würde das die
arbeiterströme in ganz Asien verbessern
wenn wir den Markt digital und dem
Hinblick auf Datenströme Vereinen würden
könnten wir China Konkurrenz machen
China competition
es werden so viele Reformen erforderlich
damit die Asien Staaten das Finanzwesen
tiefgreifend um und ausbauen könnten die
Bening
Service
ihre Währungen zu erschaffen
und regionale Faktoren in den
Hintergrund treten
man könnte seine Wirtschaftsentwicklung
selbst in die Hand nehmen
die finanzielle inklusion ist ein
Hauptaugenmerk in der Region die
finanzielle Mündigkeit ist hingegen eher
niedrig ist das eine große
Herausforderung wie wollen sie alle ins
Boot holen
muss im Bereich finanzieller Inklusion
noch aufholen ebenso wie Indien
wir sind zwei große Volkswirtschaften
wenn wir dabei Fortschritte erzielen
wird das globale Auswirkungen haben
das Asian eine Rolle für die
Weltwirtschaft spielen wird ist
unausweichlich
unsere Wirtschaft ist schon jetzt
jährlich 3 Billionen Dollar schwer
mit einem Wachstum von 5% im Jahr sind
wir in 14 Jahren bei 6 bis 7 Billionen
Dollar
die ganze Weltwirtschaft beträgt etwa
100 Billionen Dollar wir sind schon
jetzt ein nennenswerter Teil der
Weltwirtschaft
in den nächsten 14 bis 18 Jahren werden
wir noch weiter wachsen
Größe bedeutet auch Einfluss
doch Asian wird oft vorgeworfen dass die
Veränderung kraftlos sei weil sie auf
sanften Konsens setzen mit dem man keine
Veränderungen bewirken können
Verunsicherung auf der Welt muss Asian
stärker auftreten
sich in Ostasien etablieren
und der Unsicherheit mit
Multilateralismus begegnen
wir müssen uns als Mittelmacht
positionieren
China und die USA sind die großen
g2-staaten
ob sie sich streiten oder freundlich
miteinander umgehen für uns gibt das
Probleme
wir müssen die Balance finden und Japan
Korea und Asien als Mittelmacht
etablieren
was ist ihre Vision für Asian in zehn
Jahren
wir sind im Aufschwung
global betrachtet sind wir die einzige
Region die wirtschaftlich durchgehend
gut dasteht
das ist eine Folge unserer pragmatischen
Politik und davon dass wir hier gesunde
Konkurrenz fördern
in dieser Region gilt ein Wachstum von
immerhin fünf Prozent als schwache
Leistung
es gibt ein berühmtes ich glaube
afrikanisches Sprichwort
willst du schnell sein geh alleine
wollt ihr weit kommen geht zusammen
er spricht durchaus einiges für
umfassenden Konsens doch die wahre
Schönheit von Asien liegt in der
Flexibilität die einzelnen Länder und
Regionen haben politisch viel Spielraum
das zu tun was sie für richtig erachten
ohne Gängelung durch eine asienweite
Politik
Präsident Indonesiens versprach 100
Millionen neue Arbeitsplätze um den
Arbeitsmarkt für die vierte industrielle
Revolution neu zu starten hier ist Asien
the next generation
[Musik]
der Asian bereist zieht viele junge
Menschen denn das durchschnittliche
Alter liegt bei nur 29 Jahren
zur politischen Führung im Alter von 70
Jahren
was an Asien begeistert sie in Bezug auf
die nächsten zehn Jahre am meisten
ich denke es ist die nächste Generation
junge Anführer in Politik und Wirtschaft
insbesondere beim Onlinehandel
es gibt eine Generation junger
Führungspersonen sowohl in der Politik
und in der Wirtschaft als auch in der
Kunst im Medien und Entertainmentbereich
in Mode Kultur und Zivilgesellschaft die
nur auf ihren Einsatz wartet sehen
wir werden in ganz Asien in acht bis
zwölf Jahren sehen was sie bewirken
können
acht bis zwölf Jahre sind schnell vorbei
wie genau werden die neuen Anführer
Asian Formen
in acht bis zwölf Jahren wird es eine
stärkere südostasiatische Identität
geben nicht mehr so sehr eine Thai oder
Philippino Identität es deutet viel auf
eine südostasiatische eine
asia-identitätin
die junge Generation hat zwar eine
andere Wahrnehmung von Asien als wir
aber auch für sie gehört Asian bereits
dazu
identifiziert sich mit seiner Region und
die Jugend ist nun mal die Zukunft der
regionale Identität sind aber auch ein
Teil der Region Südostasien
die Vernetzung günstige Flugtickets
Auslands Visa und digitaler
Informationsaustausch verbinden uns
durch die digitale Vernetzung Wissen
junge Menschen viel mehr übereinander
Präsident Djokovic plant nach eigener
Aussage in fünf Jahren 100 Millionen
Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen
trotz des schnellen Wachstums der
größten Volkswirtschaft in Asien fällt
es vielen jungen Leuten schwer Arbeit zu
finden daher verschiebt sich der Fokus
weg von den althergebrachten Gewerben
hin zur Bildung für die vierte
industrielle Revolution
mit digitaler Technologie kann jeder ein
Unternehmer werden
mit Plattformen wie beispielsweise
bucalapag in Indonesien kann das sogar
in Grundschüler
sie verdienen über das Internet Geld mit
ihrem Hobby weil sie nahe am Markt sind
die Nachfrage besteht
so Technologie bietet Kleinunternehmern
in Indonesien Asien und auf der ganzen
Welt große Chancen
sie haben einen effizienteren
effektiveren Zugang zum Markt
das Problem ist unser Verständnis dieses
digitalen Ökosystems damit wir allen
eine faire Chance geben können
die Technologie und die digitale
Ökonomie zu verstehen ist die
schwierigste politische Diskussion
unserer Zeit
um Jobs Teilhabe und Chancen zu
generieren
in Indonesien gibt es bereits einige
Programme zur Förderung finanzieller
Inklusion
was wir Sozialprogramm der Regierung
wird bereits digitalisiert
unser Ziel fürs letzte Jahr waren 15
Millionen Familien dieses Jahr sind es
24 Millionen alles digital
wie also auch der staatliche
Personenverkehr wird digitalisiert
dadurch kommt der Bevölkerungsteil ohne
Bankkonten zum vor wodurch wir in
Indonesien die finanzielle Inklusion von
40 Prozent auf 60 Prozent und demnächst
hoffentlich auf 70% erhöhen können
[Musik]
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt sind immer ein
heikles Thema wir gehen wir mit
ungelernten Arbeitskräften um wie mit
Facharbeitern
ungelernte Arbeitskräfte werden
weiterhin ein brisantes Thema bleiben an
dem wir aber schon bilaterale arbeiten
wir sollten uns aber auch mit
Fachkräften und der Ausbildung befassen
für den nächsten Entwicklungsschritt
unserer jeweiligen Nationen und für die
Zukunft der wirtschaftlichen Integration
wird es unerlässlich sein dass wir uns
zeitnah mit diesen Bausteinen für die
wirtschaftliche Integration befassen
finanzielle Inklusion und Vernetzung
sind die großen Themen in Indonesien mit
gutem Grund Bernd der OECD zufolge sind
Kleinunternehmer für 97% der
Arbeitsplätze und 56% aller
Investitionen verantwortlich Investment
sie zu unterstützen und zu fördern
stärkt die Wirtschaft
über 60 Prozent aller Erwachsenen in
Indonesien haben Mobiltelefone
Kleinunternehmer mögen die digitale
Wirtschaft die Industrie 4.0 denn so
können Sie einfach und kostengünstig am
marktteil haben
zunächst 500.000 Indonesia mittlerweile
über eine Million
der expanding jetzt expandieren sie in
alle großen Städte Indonesiens
derartige Angebote und Kleinunternehmen
im Allgemeinen die früher durch
ungleichen Zugang zu Informationen vom
Markt ausgeschlossen an sind jetzt große
Akteure und genießen die Vorzüge
unser Hauptaugenmerk darauf
Kleinunternehmen zu fördern indem wir
ihnen mehr unternehmerische Chancen
ermöglichten entweder
Indonesien tut vieles um
Kleinunternehmer zu unterstützen
die digitale Wirtschaft das digitale
Finanzwesen und Start-ups beschleunigen
nun die Entwicklung von Kleinunternehmen
Indonesien reden wir gern vom
Kleinunternehmen dass sein eigenes
Produkt früher auf der Straße verkaufte
und jetzt dank dem Online-Handel bereits
im Export tätig ist
die technologische Revolution ist die
Zukunft wir nennen es die fünfte
Freiheit
etablierten vier Freiheiten in Asien
sind freier Verkehr von Waren
Dienstleistungen Investitionen und
Menschen die fünfte ist der Datenverkehr
wenn die wirtschaftliche Integration in
Asien gelingen soll müssen wir uns mit
dem Datenverkehr befassen
Asien ist insofern unsere Übungsgelände
auf dem wir uns zunächst zur Übung und
der Nachbarn miteinander vernetzen bevor
wir uns global öffnen
das ist eine wichtige Perspektive
besonders bedeutsam für Asian sind
Indonesiens Einhörner
ich denke Gojak hat noch viel
Wachstumspotenzial
unsere Zielmarkt ist schließlich die
gesamte Mittelschicht Südostasiens
und jetzt
milliardenschwere Firmen verbinden die
nächste Generation in Asien
indonesien ist das Land der Einhörner
tokopedia travel loca und Gojak sind
drei Firmen die das Land zum Herz der
Internetwirtschaft machten
durch das Internet und Mobiltelefone
bekommen Millionen Kleinunternehmen und
hunderte Millionen Menschen Zugang zu
Märkten und dem Finanzwesen
in Indonesien gibt es mehr als 75
Millionen Krafträder
sie in Jakarta per ride sharing zu
vermieten schien also eine gute Idee zu
sein so gut dass gotchek jetzt einen
Marktwert von über 10 Milliarden Dollar
erreichte
Gojak hat großen Einfluss in Asien denn
sie bieten auch Logistik Lebensmittel
und fintech und expandieren immer weiter
wir hatten nach nur zwei drei Monaten
einen Anteil von 30 bis 35 Prozent am
Zweiradmarkt in Vietnam
wir waren überrascht wie schnell sich
das entwickelte sicher auch ein Erfolg
der App aber es geht auch darum neue
Branchen zu erschließen und die
Reichweite unserer Dienste in Indonesien
unserem größten Markt zu erhöhen
Investoren zu denen Schwergewichte wie
Google
Band j.d.g
Thematik und auch made one gehören
bereits erkennen dass wir in allen
wichtigen Industriezweigen in denen wir
aktiv sind nach der Weltspitze Streben
um die erste globale super-app für alle
alltäglichen Bedürfnisse zu erstellen
Technologie vereinfacht diese
Integration zusätzlich
die wirtschaftseinhörner und die
digitale Wirtschaft in Asien sind ein
Faktor für die Beschleunigung dieser
Integration
fester
loca sie sind alle regional aktiv und
werdende Impulsgeber für die weitere
Integration der Wirtschaft in ganz Asien
sein die Asian economy to integriert
die Sättigung auf dem Verbrauchermarkt
ist im Vergleich zu China immer noch
verschwinden klein
andere Transport Lebensmittel
zahlungsdienstleistungs Logistik und
digitalbranchen können noch stark
wachsen also stehen wir immer noch am
Anfang
hat also noch gewaltiges
Wachstumspotenzial denn unsere
potenzielle Zielgruppe ist die gesamte
Mittelschicht Südostasiens
glücklicherweise hat Präsident Djokovic
einen guten Draht zum Millennials und
der Generation Z der kommenden
Generation
bei Fernsehdebatten im Wahlkampf brachte
er Themen wie eSports und
videospielturniere zur Sprache ebenso
wie den Online-Handel die digitale
Wirtschaft und wirtschaftseinhörner
auf der messtec That ich bin
zuversichtlich dass die Ziele und
Wünsche der Millennials und der
Generation Z im Rahmen der kommenden
Führung in Asien deutlich stärker zum
Tragen kommen werden
China ist seit zehn Jahren der größte
Handelspartner von Asien
einen Handelskurs zwischen Peking und
Washington zu finden ist angesichts der
Spannungen nur eine von vielen
außenpolitischen Herausforderungen
die Probleme im Südchinesischen Meer
Spalten uns
das transpazifische Handelsabkommen
spaltet uns und doch besteht Asian fort
und macht weiter Fortschritte wenn auch
in manchen Jahren etwas langsamer
insgesamt sind wir jedoch immer gewillt
uns der nächsten Herausforderung zu
stellen
wir sind buchstäblich ein Drehkreuz des
Welthandels
90 Prozent des ölhandels aus dem nahen
in den fernen Osten läuft über
Indonesien durch die Straße von Malaga
dadurch sind wir sehr offen für den
internationalen Handel sowie in gewisser
Weise für investitionstourismus und
haben eine hohe Toleranz für eine
Vielzahl anderer Kulturen aus aller Welt
entwickelt
wenn wir zehn Jahre in die Zukunft
blicken müssen wir Asien Japan Südkorea
und China gemeinsam betrachten
Dynamik all dieser ostasiatischen Länder
die beschleunigte Integration
auf der integrierte langsam zieht die
Integration sogar
reizvoll sich mit all diesen Ländern zu
vernetzen und nicht bevorzugt nur
innerhalb von
für mich ist das Glas halb voll ich bin
zuversichtlich dass Asian sich weiterhin
behaupten kann
und dass die Krise des globalen
Handelssystems und des Multilateralismus
für uns eine Warnung oder nach
Möglichkeit etwas Positives eine Chance
darstellen wird
starken können und das Gleichgewicht in
dieser zunehmend polarisierten Welt
darstellen
mit einer starken regionalen Präsenz und
einer festen Stimme und Mitsprache
angesichts der multilateralen und
regionalen Verunsicherung
am meisten verändern
es wird anders als alles bisher da
gewesen sein jetzt haben denn es
überschneidet sich mit dem Aufkommen von
Industrie 4.0 Cloud Computing und
künstliche Intelligenz der ganzen
Zukunftstechnologie
die Bevölkerung Südostasiens von Asien
hat sich als unglaublich offen für neue
Technologie erwiesen für soziale Medien
mehr als wohl überall sonst auf der Welt
wiesfische diese Fische verbringen bis
zu drei Monate auf See um mit einem Fang
im Wert von 70.000 Dollar zurückzukehren
solche Traditionsunternehmen waren die
Lebensader Indonesiens doch der
generationenwandel läutet eine neue
Zukunft ein
die strahlende Silhouette von Singapur
der finanzdrehscheibe von Asien und eine
der teuersten Städte der Welt
in Singapur treffen privates
Unternehmertum und Geld aufeinander ein
Großteil der Erfolgsgeschichte Asians
geht auf privates Unternehmertum zurück
Asian wächst bei Nacht wenn die
Regierung schläft
bis zu 60 Prozent aller Projekte in
Asien werden über die Banken Singapurs
finanziert
die Privatwirtschaft hat ihre Wünsche
der Staat hingegen ist für sein Volk
verantwortlich und muss hier vermitteln
damit alles zusammenpasst
wenn wir Privatwirtschaft und
öffentliche Hand bündeln können wir die
nötigen Mittel für diese Projekte
aufbringen
die Finanzierung der Infrastruktur ist
eine der Herausforderungen für die
nächste Generation in Asien
ich bin Hass Linde Armin willkommen in
Singapur der Stadtstaat macht mit knapp
sechs Millionen Einwohnern weniger als
ein Prozent der Bevölkerung von Asien
aber fast 12 Prozent der
Wirtschaftsleistung aus
Singapur ist das Zentrum für Finanzen
und Infrastruktur Südostasiens
etwas wie Singapur gibt es nirgendwo
sonst in der Region
die kleine Insel ist über den größten
Flughafen der Region und in zweitgrößten
Containerhafen der Welt mit dem Rest der
Welt verbunden
die Stadt bietet hochentwickelte
Finanzmärkte Bildung und Fachkompetenz
in Asien gibt es sowohl kleine Länder
die in der Entwicklung hinterherhinken
als auch auf der anderen Seite
hochmoderne Industrienationen wie
Singapur die am völlig anderen Ende des
Spektrums stehen
hier also einen homogenen Markt mit
homogenem Kaufverhalten und gleichen
Chancen anzunehmen spiegelt
offensichtlich nicht die Realität wieder
du
investauren aus aller Welt sagen zu
Investitionen in Asien immer wieder ihre
Entscheidung viele für Indochine anders
aus als für Thailand oder Singapur
daran scheitert es in Qualität leider
oft
DBS ist die größte Bank Südostasiens die
Hälfte ihrer Geschäfte entfällt auf
Singapur und die Hälfte ihres Umsatzes
stammt aus institutional Banking ein
Großteil der Erfolgsgeschichte Asians
geht auf privates Unternehmertum zurück
übrigens
bei Nacht wenn die Regierung schläft für
mich ist die Privatwirtschaft die
treibende Kraft der Integration
die Firmen streben danach
grenzübergreifend zusammenzuarbeiten und
die Verbraucher werden ihrerseits mit
den Füßen wählen
die Privatwirtschaft und Einzelpersonen
treiben die Geschichte voran und nehmen
dabei die Regierung und den staatlichen
Sektor mit
die meisten Regierungen wollen das
gleiche ihr Volk glücklich machen wofür
sie Infrastruktur brauchen
verschiedene Länder verfolgen hierbei
verschiedene Ansätze
lassen sich stark auf die
Privatwirtschaft andere setzen auf
staatliche Betriebe
ein very muching ich bin ein Verfechter
öffentlich privater Partnerschaften
die engagieren uns auf diese Art auf den
Philippinen und ich glaube dass der
private Sektor insbesondere in
Anbetracht seines wachsenden Budgets in
der Pflicht steht sich gewissenhaft und
mit gebotenem Ernst an bisher
üblicherweise staatlichen Projekten zu
beteiligen
man muss es aus der Perspektive der
Privatwirtschaft sehen
sie werden nur handeln wenn die Projekte
eine angemessene Rendite versprechen
muss man dafür sorgen dass alles gut
strukturiert ist
wobei auch der regulatorische Rahmen der
Investitionen von Bedeutung ist
die Asiatische Entwicklungsbank rechnet
für die infrastrukturbedürfnisse in
Asien mit erforderlichen Ausgaben von
0,1 Billionen Dollar in zehn Jahren
Singapur hat mit infrastructure Asia
eine zentrale Anlaufstelle eingerichtet
[Musik]
der Ausbau der Kompetenzen der Länder
ist auch von Bedeutung
sind die Beamten oder anderweitige
verantwortliche eines Landes müssen im
Stande sein ein vorgeschlagenes
strukturiertes Projekt einschätzen zu
können
man will hier nicht nur ein Projekt
umsetzen sondern seinem Volk einen
Mehrwert bieten also Arbeitsplätze den
Austausch von Fachwissen und natürlich
die direkten Vorteile des Projekts
die beiden Bereiche müssen
zusammenarbeiten denn der Staatssektor
muss sie schließlich sowohl bei den
Richtlinien als auch bei der
Infrastruktur mit der Privatwirtschaft
koordinieren
die öffentliche Hand muss also an der
Entwicklung von zahlungsmechanismen
ebenso wie an der Harmonisierung von
Kapitalmärkten beteiligt sein
ohne Zusammenarbeit geht es nicht auch
wenn die Privatwirtschaft oft
federführend sein wird
Singapur ist für viele Länder ein
Vorbild
nicht nur in Asien sondern auf der
ganzen Welt
insbesondere im Hinblick darauf dass die
öffentliche Hand sehr darauf bedacht ist
sich bestmöglich auf Trends in der
Privatwirtschaft und weltweit
beobachtete Entwicklungen einzustellen
[Musik]
Konzerne Thailands das
Infrastrukturunternehmen ist seit über
100 Jahren in der Region von Asien aktiv
die Glasfront des Hauptsitzes erlaubt
einen Blick auf den Hauptbahnhof von
Bangkok der bald schnellzuglinien von
Singapur bis nach China verbinden wird
Highline Thailand investiert stark in
Infrastruktur ebenso wie es auch Länder
wie Vietnam und Indonesien tun
wir beobachten auch den Trend die
Infrastrukturen der Länder von Asien mit
China zu vernetzen
wir gehen also davon aus dass der
Schwerpunkt zumindest staatliche
Investitionen in den kommenden zehn
Jahren auf der Infrastruktur liegen wird
[Musik]
die Länder wollen für die aufstrebende
Mittelschicht Städte bauen große wie
kleine
sie müssen also viele Städte planen und
dabei alles mögliche Bedenken
Abfallmanagement Hygiene
Wasserversorgung Elektrizität und
Kommunikation sind einige der
wiederkehrenden Kernpunkte in den
Ländern rund um Singapur
Privatwirtschaft und öffentliche Hand
bündeln können wir die nötigen Mittel
für diese Projekte aufbringen
die meisten Länder in Asien hinken bei
der Infrastrukturentwicklung hinterher
was auch am lobenswerten starken
Wachstum liegt doch die massive
Verstädterung wie wir sie in den
Großstädten Manila Jakarta und Bangkok
beobachten können
offenbart uns wie groß der Bedarf an
zukunftsfähiger Infrastruktur
tatsächlich ist
jedes Land braucht einen
maßgeschneiderten Ansatz im
hochentwickelten Singapur haben wir es
mit ganz anderen Herausforderungen zu
tun als beispielsweise in Myanmar Laos
oder Kambodscha
darum passen wir unsere Herangehensweise
für die jeweiligen Länder und ihre
Bedürfnisse an damit wir die richtigen
Lösungen anbieten können
vor 130 Jahren installierte General
Electric auf den Philippinen die erste
Glühbirne
als nächstes sehen wir uns die
Energieversorgung für die Zukunft von
Asien an
65 Millionen Menschen ein Zehntel der
Bevölkerung lebt ohne Elektrizität in
manchen Ländern hat nicht mal ein
drittelstrom
[Musik]
Asian ist im Wandel nicht nur bei der
Vernetzung und Inklusion sondern auch in
Sachen Nachhaltigkeit
Kohle ist hier der Hauptlieferant für
Strom doch der Bedarf ist in den letzten
15 Jahren um 60% gestiegen
grüß Gott Sixty five 65 Millionen
Menschen ein Zehntel der Bevölkerung
lebt ohne Elektrizität in manchen
Ländern hat nicht mal ein drittelstrom
in Singapur wiederum 100 Prozent
die Energiegewinnung muss daher
unbedingt ausgebaut werden
wir fokussieren uns auf diesem Bereich
und bieten glücklicherweise ein
vollständiges Portfolio an erneuerbaren
Lösungen Wind Sonne Energiespeicher aber
auch thermische Technologien wie Gas und
Kohle
so jedes Land hat seine eigene Situation
und eigene Ressourcen manche haben keine
Ressourcen und müssen importieren darum
brauchen Sie alle individuelle Lösungen
damit die Länder der Region ihr
Potenzial entfalten können brauchen sie
Energieversorgung was sind hierbei die
Herausforderungen
Problem ist dass die Energieversorgung
in der Vergangenheit über herkömmliche
fossile Energieträger erfolgte jetzt
aber wurde Klimaschutz und
Nachhaltigkeit ein großes Thema mit
gutem Grund
den Energiebedarf und das Verlangen nach
Nachhaltigkeit ins Gleichgewicht zu
bringen ist die Herausforderung
glücklicherweise haben sich
Preisunterschied und Kosteneffizienz
erneuerbarer Energien in den letzten
fünf Jahren stark verbessert
somit sehen wir eine Chance den Anteil
erneuerbarer Energien deutlich zu
erhöhen
die Ayala Group ist eines der ältesten
und größten Konglomerate der Philippinen
die Energiesparte arbeitet an
milliardenschwerden Projekten für
erneuerbare Energiequellen auf den
Philippinen in Indonesien und in Vietnam
hat sich das Ziel gesetzt bis 2025 23
Prozent seines Strom aus erneuerbaren
Quellen zu beziehen die meisten
Regierungen haben mittlerweile ein viel
stärkeres Bewusstsein dafür und Streben
nach erneuerbarer Energie wir müssen
unsere Portfolio entsprechend anpassen
und uns hier stärker einbringen die
Deckung des Energiebedarfs auf
nachhaltige Weise ist die große
Herausforderung sowohl für die
Privatwirtschaft als auch für die
öffentliche Hand
das Ziel der Nachhaltigkeit musste man
schon immer als Gleichgewicht Betrachten
der Klimawandel ist ein großes Problem
wohl das größte Problem der nächsten 10
15 Jahre aber auch hier gibt es nirgends
die radikale Antwort wäre sämtliche
Nutzung fossiler Energieträger
einzustellen
Südostasien wird aber in den kommenden
10 15 Jahren gewaltigen Energiebedarf
haben weshalb es heute keine echte
Alternative dazu gibt
Banken wie DBS und eaip wollen nur noch
grüne nachhaltige Projekte unterstützen
ist
das in einer Region die nach günstiger
Energie verlangt realistisch wo Kohle
noch die vorherrschende Energiequelle
ist
ich denke die Welt und auch die Banken
tun hier das Richtige und verlagern den
Fokus hin zu Nachhaltigkeit
wir haben unsererseits das langfrist
Ziel dass die Hälfte der
Energieproduktion unseres Portfolios aus
nachhaltigen Quellen stammen Zahlen es
geht immer um ein Gleichgewicht ich sehe
mich nicht als
radikalneuerbarer Energiequellen gehen
aber es gibt Anwendungsfälle bei denen
fossile Energieträger noch immer die
effizienteste Lösung sind
wir müssen zwar den Energiebedarf
unserer Zeit decken können aber nicht
ewig so weitermachen da die Zukunft
sonst düster aussieht
brauchen wir die Balance und müssen dann
den Anteil thermische Energie verringern
wobei auch Banken eine wichtige Rolle
spielen
wir müssen den Menschen Alternativen
bieten also finanzieren wir verstärkt
erneuerbare Projekte Solarstrom
Windenergie und auch Biomasse
der US-Gigant General Electric sieht in
Südostasien ein gewaltiges
Wachstumspotenzial der Umsatz des
Unternehmens in der Region hat sich in
acht Jahren auf 7 Milliarden Dollar
verdoppelt das Unternehmen hat in der
Region 10.000 Beschäftigte
Wachstumschance liegt in enger
Zusammenarbeit der Länder miteinander in
Laos wird im Norden viel Energie für den
Export nach Vietnam und Thailand
produziert
im Süden viel Energie aus Vietnam und
Thailand importiert wird vom Vietnam in
Thailand der Stromnetz ist also der
Schlüssel dazu die Energie am richtigen
Ort nutzen zu können
in Bezug auf die physische Infrastruktur
und die Vernetzung der Länder
untereinander hat die Region noch Luft
nach oben
inklusives Wachstum und inklusive
Entwicklung stehen im Fokus
wie können Sie irgendwie Indonesien
einem riesigen Archipel mit 17.000
Inseln helfen die Lücke zu schließen
indonesien ist ein interessantes
Beispiel
hier sind sowohl große Kraftwerke
erforderlich wie auf Java oder Sumatra
in dicht besiedelten Gebieten als auch
kleinere Systeme auf fossiler Basis für
die entlegenen Regionen
wir haben erst kürzlich viele entlegene
Inseln elektrifiziert mit größtenteils
autonomen mobilen Lösungen
für die Regierung war es ein großer
Erfolg Energie in Regionen zu bringen
die vorher keine Stromversorgung hatten
fast alle Länder haben
infrastrukturpläne in Höhe von hunderten
Milliarden Dollar und dennoch fehlt es
in Südostasien markant an Infrastruktur
warum was wäre die wichtigste Maßnahme
dagegen
Wachstum war so gewaltig dass wir erst
wieder aufholen müssen
mit Infrastruktur können wir das
Wachstum aber auf lange Sicht aufrecht
erhalten ich bin der Ansicht dass wir
insbesondere in wirtschaftlichen
Schwerpunkten die Infrastruktur
vorausschauend und mit ausreichend
Reserven ausbauen sollten um das
Wachstum aufrechtzuerhalten Regierungen
müssen hierbei aber auch politische und
gesellschaftliche Probleme Bedenken
weshalb nicht immer alles perfekt laufen
kann
als nächstes betrachten wir wie Vietnam
den Wandel begrüßt von Hanoi bis Ho Chi
Minh
der größte Nutzen von fintech sind
verringerte Kosten für so gut wie alles
Technologie ist grundsätzlich
deflationär die Kosten für Zugang und
Transaktionen sinken Kunden können
bessere Angebote bekommen
wenn die Kosten also sinken können auch
weniger weit entwickelte Länder eine
bessere Abdeckung ihrer Finanzsysteme
erreichen
ich sehe hier keine Nachteile
ist da unsere Länder arbeiten daran
Geschäftstätigkeiten zu erleichtern
und ebenso über Gesetze und Richtlinien
Firmen die richtigen Anreize zu bieten
in diesen Ländern zu investieren
es ist nicht einfach über Landesgrenzen
und vor allem Steuer- und Rechtsbereiche
hinweg tätig zu
[Musik]
seiner Meinung nach unsere aktuell
größte Herausforderung
die großen Städte in Asien werden sich
stark modernisieren und Smart Cities
werden sie werden sich an die
Anforderungen der Zukunft anpassen
nachhaltiger und umweltfreundlicher
werden mit weniger Stau auf der Straße
es gibt bis dahin noch viel zu tun aber
die Art wie Städte funktionieren und mit
Energie versorgt werden wird sich in den
nächsten Jahren drastisch ändern
öffentlich privaten Partnerschaften um
wirklich gesellschaftlich nützliche
Themen wie öffentlichen Nahverkehr geht
grundlegende Infrastruktur für die
Verbindung von Menschen und Wirtschaft
wird daraus eine inklusive Komponente
die Menschen in allen Bereichen betrifft
insbesondere in den unteren
Gesellschaftsschichten sind
Verkehrsprojekte besonders wichtig da es
in Südostasien sonst sehr schwierig ist
sich in der Stadt zu bewegen
[Musik]
wartete Wirtschaftswachstum der
Philippinen wurde für 2019 mit fast
sieben Prozent von den fünf größten
Volkswirtschaften von Asien am höchsten
eingeschätzt Vietnam gehört nicht zu
ihnen ist aber auf einem ähnlichen Kurs
[Musik]
ich befasse mich jetzt schon seit über
20 Jahren mit Vietnam und konnte den
Wandel weg von strikter staatlicher
Kontrolle hin zu einer flexibleren
Marktwirtschaft mit Privatkapital
deutlich beobachten
die Richtung scheint klar aber sie haben
noch einen weiten Weg vor sich
verglichen mit den marktorientierten
asian-staaten ist es in Vietnam immer
noch deutlich schwerer etwas auf die
Beine zu stellen
sie intensivieren ihr Investment in
erneuerbare Energien in Vietnam warum
Vietnam sie boten Investoren für kurze
Zeit reizvolle Zölle und Gebühren wenn
man überlegt wo man investieren will und
Regierung plötzlich Anreize schafft
zieht das natürlich Kapital an
Vietnam war sehr offen für spezifische
nachhaltige Projekte
wir hatten das Know-how ein geeignetes
Team und die finanziellen Mittel das
Projekt durchzuführen
und Vietnam war bezüglich der
investitionsangebote sehr großzügig also
ergriffen wir die Chance und machten uns
ans Werk
zum großen Projekten fällt mir als
erstes unsere Beteiligung am
pedrochemiekomplex in Südvietnam ein
nahe ho chi-minh-stadt
da ging es um knapp 5,4 Milliarden
US-Dollar
der Bau hat bereits begonnen ein Zehntel
ist schon geschafft
wir rechnen damit dass es in dreieinhalb
oder vier Jahren kommerziell im Betrieb
gehen kann
es ist der erste petrusemische Komplex
in Vietnam
was ist die größte Herausforderung für
Asia
fangen wir zuerst mit etwas Positivem an
bevor wir von den Problemen reden
die Region macht sich sehr gut das
Gesamtwachstum in Südostasien ganz Asien
ist ein strahlendes Vorbild und wird das
auch noch eine Weile bleiben
die Herausforderung besteht darin dass
Wachstum nachhaltig planbar und
langfristig haltbar zu machen
wie Ihr sehen faszinierende
Entwicklungen wie gewaltige
Urbanisierung was natürlich eine
Infrastruktur Herausforderung darstellt
das lässt sich in allen großen Städten
Südostasiens beobachten
es gibt mittlerweile etwa 1.800
Flugzeuge in Asien
in den nächsten zehn Jahren werden
nochmals 2.200 dazukommen
das hört sich also mehr als verdoppeln
ebenso die Energieversorgung heute haben
wir eine Leistung von 260 Gigawatt und
in den nächsten zehn Jahren kommen
nochmal 200 Gigawatt dazu das gleiche im
Gesundheitswesen das wächst auch seit
Jahren stetig um etwa zehn Prozent in
der Region sind tausende neue
Krankenhäuser geplant
auch die Vernetzung der Menschen wird
besser
das liegt zum Teil an Technologien die
es uns erlauben kulturelle und
sprachliche Barrieren einfacher zu
überwinden
für mich persönlich ist das
die bedeutendste Verbesserung die ich
zwischen den Ländern von Asien in den
letzten vier oder fünf Jahren beobachten
konnte
ein großer Unterschied ist die
Verbreitung von Marken aus Asien
das ist noch ein neues Phänomen ob es
nun um reisha grap oder goject geht
gerade im Technologiesektor treten
Marken aus Asien immer stärker in den
Vordergrund anders als früher das hat
sich geändert
die andere Veränderung ist der Wunsch
und das behutsame Streben nach
Marktintegration
Staatspolitik und Privates
Unternehmertum innerhalb und über
Grenzen hinweg Partnerschaften und
geteilter Wohlstand im Namen des Volkes
sie sind die Zukunft von Asien
technologieaffin und mobil sind sie eine
völlig neuart Verbraucher
nur noch wischen und fertig schnell
einfach intuitiv
mehr als ein Drittel der 640 Millionen
Menschen von Asien sind zwischen 15 und
34 wir sind eine der beliebtesten Marken
bei Jugendlichen und Millennials perfekt
für eine der jüngsten Bevölkerungen der
Welt der Wandel erschafft Chancen
wer sind Asian schafft kann es überall
schaffen
Freizeit Lifestyle Online-Handel und
Führung heute sind alle voller
Leidenschaft und Zuversicht mit Know-how
aus aller Welt
sie sind die nächste Generation in Asien
willkommen in Bangkok der Hauptstadt
Thailands der zweitgrößten
Volkswirtschaft von Asien die wie ganz
Südostasien den Höhenflug der
online-wirtschaft nutzen will
die ganze Region sitzt dabei auf eine
neue jüngere verbraucherschicht
das Durchschnittsalter liegt bei nur 29
Jahren somit sind Millennials die
treibende Kraft einer florierenden
Mittelschicht der bis 2030 330 Millionen
Menschen angehören könnten mehr als das
Doppelte verglichen mit 2019
in den letzten 30 Jahren hat sich so
viel verändert als sie hierher kam und
zwar Teil aussah aber kein Wortteil
sprach zog ich allerlei komische Blicke
an
heute sind alle voller Leidenschaft und
Zuversicht mit Know-how aus aller Welt
die sogenannten Meeresschildkröten
kommen zurück sie waren im Ausland und
bringen nun das Wissen und die
Leidenschaft aus aller Welt zurück in
ihre Heimat
Technologie wird aktuelle Entwicklungen
nur beschleunigen
alles wird schneller besser und
günstiger
Indonesien und ganz Asien gibt es viele
junge und hart arbeitende Menschen die
sehr vernetzt sind und Probleme lösen
wollen
Technologie wird ganz Asia nur helfen
und Asien zu etwas bringen kann schafft
es überall
umgekehrt nicht unbedingt
plötzlich müssen wir nicht mehr wie
früher traditionelle Logistik und
Telekommunikationsnetze aufbauen 5g
breitet sich zum Beispiel sehr schnell
in der Region aus
der digitale Konsum ist gewaltig ohne
wie bisher üblich lange vorlaufphasen
so die nächsten zwei oder drei Jahre
werden in Südostasien die kritische
Phase sein das Wachstum in den kommenden
15 Jahren wird gewaltig
sowohl in Bezug auf Konsum als auch
Investitionen und die Entwicklung der
ganzen
es kommen gerade viele Millennials
zurück die sich im Ausland ausbilden
ließen und andere Länder kennenlernten
zeitgleich steigt das Bildungsniveau der
Arbeiterschaft in nie dagewesene Maße
generations of Warcraft unsere
Generation ist besser ausgebildet und
viel reicher als alle vor uns
Rachel aus Vater war der malaysische
Immobilien und investment-magnat labunan
mit zwei Freunden mit ähnlichem
Hintergrund wollte sie den größten
unabhängigen Investmentfonds
Südostasiens erschaffen independent
Investment Fund Force habe ich
südostasien ist für uns sehr
interessanteste Markt und wird es wegen
der jungen Bevölkerung auch noch 10 15
Jahre lang bleiben
der generationenwandel verändert die
Politik der Konsum ist gewaltig und es
gibt eine hochgebildete sehr mobile
population die zum Teil auch von außen
nach Südostasien einreist
wir sollten nicht außer Acht lassen dass
es nicht nur um diejenigen geht die
bereits da sind sondern dass viele sogar
hierher kommen wollen
somit werden viele innovative Ideen in
diesen Teil der Welt gelangen
Asian hat in den letzten 60 Jahren
gewaltige Fortschritte gemacht Handel
und Wirtschaftsleistung sind um das 20
bis 30-fache gestiegen
Technologie kann diese Entwicklung noch
weiter beschleunigen denn sie macht
nicht nur die Produktion schneller
besser und günstiger sondern löst auch
Probleme schneller besser und günstiger
so again in Indonesien und ganz Asien
können viele Probleme bei der
Infrastruktur im Zahlungsverkehr in
Bezug auf Arbeitskräfte und Know-how
durch Technologie gelöst werden
es ist für uns in Südostasien
unglaublich wichtig in Talente zu
investieren wir haben gerade erst unsere
Zentrale in Singapur eingeweiht eine
fintech-zentrale in Malaysia
eingerichtet und bilden dadurch von
Beginn an hunderte Menschen aus
zusätzlich bringen wir Experten aus
Silicon Valley und Europa hierher um den
Austausch zu fördern
wir Talente in der gesamten Region
fördern
[Musik]
von milliang ist ein Unternehmer aus
Asien im Höhenflug und wurde durch die
IPO seiner Firma Razer Milliardär
der gebürtige Singapurer will seinem
Unternehmen mit Sitz im Silicon Valley
in Südostasien zu einem neuen
Wachstumsschub verhelfen wir sehen
Südostasien als einen gewaltigen
Wachstumsmarkt für uns wie unser
Unternehmen
die sehr junge Bevölkerung ist überaus
technologieafien und verlangt geradezu
nach Konsum und
entertainmentige Chance sofern wir es
schaffen passende Produkte für die
Bevölkerung der Region anzubieten
unsere digitale Wirtschaft ist China
zehn Jahre hinterher aber wir holen
schneller auf als alle vor uns
China die USA und Europa brauchten viel
länger für den Ausbau der digitalen
Wirtschaft
wir stehen noch am Anfang aber bewegen
uns schon schneller als alle anderen
Wirtschaftszonen zuvor
eine Beispiele für die Vernetzung
Südostasiens die Philippinen führen
weltweit bei der Nutzung sozialer Medien
Indonesien bei der Handynutzung für den
Online-Handel und Thailand beim
internet-browsing über das Handy
unsere Internetnutzung ist hochgradig
mobil
wir sind vielmehr unterwegs als die
Generation vor uns
Technologie meiner Meinung nach
schneller anpassungsfähiger und
intuitiver werden
anstatt fünf Schritten brauchen wir nur
noch zwei wir wischen und sind fertig
schnell einfach und intuitiv
ich bin 2011 als zweiter Mitarbeiter von
lasada in die tech-branche eingestiegen
damals hatten nur 20% der Menschen in
Thailand Internetzugang heute sind es 70
oder 80 Prozent
sprich jeder hat mindestens ein Handy
das musste sich erst entwickeln
heutzutage kann sogar mein Mann aus
Norwegen der in Thailand lebt aber kein
Wort Gericht überall hinkommen
und ich rede nicht nur von Taxis er kann
Geschäfte machen mit Anwälten reden
Märkte erschließen
es hat sich so viel getan allein schon
in Bangkok
Südostasiens online Wirtschaft soll sich
durch die Verbreitung des Internets in
den nächsten fünf Jahren mindestens
verdreifachen auf bis zu 250 Milliarden
Dollar
zwar verspricht die digitale Wirtschaft
der jungen Generation von Asien
mannigfaltige Chancen doch Asian muss
den Wandel noch vollziehen
zwar alt aber nicht reich werden
das weltweite Angebot im Internet wächst
und der Anteil von letzter Menschen ist
in manchen Ländern sehr hoch während ein
großer Teil von Asien noch nicht mit
Industrienationen mithalten kann
wer in Indonesien das Internet nutzen
kann macht regen Gebrauch davon während
über 30% der Bevölkerung noch gar keinen
Zugang haben von Gesundheit und Bildung
ganz zu schweigen
droht Indonesien alt zu werden bevor der
Reichtum kommt
das ist eine verbreitete Ansicht wenn
wir nicht aufpassen könnte aus uns ein
Land mit mittlerem Einkommen werden
somit würden die Vorhersagen Indonesien
könnte in 20 oder 30 Jahren Platz fünf
besetzen reine Fantasie bleiben
so genau daran will Präsident djokovi
arbeiten
wir müssen uns auf Bedürfnisse
konzentrieren auf Prozesse ebenso wie
die weiche Infrastruktur
Demografie ist Schlüssel zum Erfolg
die Demografie ist aber auch die
Herausforderung wir müssen die richtige
Bildung und die richtigen Einstellungen
vermitteln
[Musik]
Brothers eine indonesischen
Investmentfirma die in allen Bereichen
tätig ist vom Bergbau bis zur
Telekommunikation
vor damit die Inklusion Erfolg hat
braucht es gerechte Bildung
wie soll das funktionieren
nach dem Ausbau der harten Infrastruktur
drücken helfen und Straßen steht der
Ausbau der weichen Infrastruktur an
Gesundheit und Bildung
doch welche Bildung ist am besten für
die Industrialisierung 4.0 geeignet
wir müssen ja nicht nur gute Schüler
ausbilden sondern brauchen auch ebenso
gute Lehrerbildung
zum Thema Bildung für die
die Millennials hier sind von dem Thema
geradezu besessen
es geht nicht nur um Work-Life-Balance
sondern um Arbeit leben Spiel und lernen
das Lernen findet nicht länger nur von
oben herab statt sondern auch
andersherum
viele junge Menschen sehnen sich nach
Orten an denen sie etwas lernen aber
gleichzeitig auch spielen können
ich war heute erst bei drei
bildungsstart-ups sie warten nicht auf
die Reformen des thailändischen
Bildungsministeriums
ebenso in Indonesien den Philippinen es
ist quasi das gleiche in ganz
Südostasien
ab alle Regulierungen rein pragmatisch
an
was braucht man wirklich um zu überleben
einen Universitätsabschluss nicht jeder
wird dann Mark Zuckerberg solche
aber man kann Fähigkeiten erlernen um
damit sein Geld zu verdienen
shannon war 2012 Mitbegründerin eine
Online-Handelsplattform für Frauen jetzt
berät Sie die Investmentfirma
gobi-partners zu Text Startups in
Südostasien
ich werde ständig nach dem nächsten
Einhorn gefragt
Thailand ist aber für den Aufbau einer
Firma hier überhaupt nicht geeignet
deshalb ist uns alle nach Singapur zieht
because Investitionen von Firmen und
Initiativen wie thermasek und spring
davon gibt es in Thailand zu wenig
das erste Teil Einhorn wird also auch
eine Firma mit Sitz in Singapur sein
wenn man heute von Start-ups redet geht
es oft um das Silicon Valley oder
Shenzhen in China
Südostasien irgendwann auch so
etablieren können
es geschieht bereits bei uns entstehen
bereits technologie-einhörner
aber nicht so sehr wie in China
das wird sich voraussichtlich in den
nächsten Jahren deutlich ändern
in diesem Teil der Welt entstehen viel
mehr textart-ups
selbst wir kommen aus dem Silicon Valley
zurück um nach interessanten Firmen und
Start-ups zu suchen in die wir
investieren können
ich sehe hier in Südostasien folglich
vor allem gewaltige Chancen
Valley bekommt aktuell starke Konkurrenz
aus Shenzen für Südostasien irgendwann
auch bei diesem Rennen mitmischen
ich denke schon ich kenne ein paar Leute
die ihre Start-ups aus den USA nach
Vietnam verlegen denn hier bekommen Sie
Fachkräfte für ein Viertel der
Arbeitskosten
Kosten sind ein großer Faktor und unser
Markt hier ist sehr konkurrenzfähig mit
gut ausgebildeten Fachkräften warum also
nicht
was steht dem im Weg
die Politik wir müssen einen besseren
politischen Umgang mit der
Bewegungsfreiheit ausländische
Arbeitskräfte finden
die Wirtschaft Südostasiens ist noch
nicht gut genug integriert insbesondere
im Vergleich mit Europa sind wir wieder
in Bezug auf fachkräftemobilität noch
bei Währungen konkurrenzfähig
unsere Währungen fluktuieren stark und
willkürlich
die Politik gibt die
Entwicklungsbedingungen für ganz
Südostasien
Vorrat
die Ambitionen der jungen Generationen
werden für die Regierungen zunehmend
problematisch was sind die
Herausforderungen
manche Regierungen sehen sie als Problem
andere als Chance
die junge Generation bezieht ihre und
Informationen nicht mehr aus
traditionellen Quellen
sie gehen weniger ins Kino lesen keine
Zeitung und sehen nicht fern manche
haben auch keinen Fernseher was tun sie
dann sie spielen Videospiele
sie nutzen gerne virtuelle Währungen und
beziehen Informationen aus sozialen
Medien
viele Regierungen erlernen den Umgang
mit ihnen gerade neu
in welchen Bereichen haben die
Millennials wie viel beigetragen
das ist ein interessante Frage
ich habe mich das öfteren darüber
unterhalten wie die neue Regierung von
Malaysia ihre Wirtschaft regelt
ich bin der Meinung dass ihre Sache
besser machen als ihre Vorgänger wobei
mir die meisten Ökonomen widersprechen
würden
muss ich zwei Stunden anstehen
beim NAG du musst dich sogar fünf
Stunden warten
was die Wirtschaftsleistung angeht
konnten wir im diesjährigen Bericht
sehen dass der private Verbrauch in
Malaysia ganz Malaysia über den
Erwartungen lag bei das liegt nicht an
Infrastruktur oder öffentlichen
Einrichtungen es ist die
Privatwirtschaft es gibt einfach eine
Nischenmarkt der vernachlässigt wurde
die Ausgaben der Millennials für
Verbrauchsgüter
gleich sehen wir uns an wie die nächste
Generation von Asien eine einmalige
Chance für die Zukunft ergreift
die Asien Integration die Integration
von Asian läuft so gut wie es geht wir
müssen da realistisch bleiben
die zehn Länder sind wirtschaftlich
verschieden weit entwickelt es ist
schwierig sie als Einheit mit
identischen Regeln und Zellen zu
betrachten das geht einfach nicht
Asien wird eine große Region sein das
Wachstum die Stabilität die
demografische Entwicklung all diese
Faktoren tragen zum Wachstum in der
Region bei
Region ist auch wirtschaftlich
vielfältig
Thailand hat seine Stärken ebenso
Malaysia Singapur Vietnam Indonesien die
Philippinen Laos Kambodscha und Myanmar
dieser Region steht großes bevor
die junge Generation Kambodschas hat
viel Energie und sehnt sich nach Bildung
[Musik]
den Wandel hin zu digitalisierten
Industrie und wie die Regierung sagt
elektronischen Wirtschaft zu vollziehen
brauchen wir Fähigkeiten und Kompetenz
darum müssen wir unser Bildungssystem
reformieren um die Industrie in
Kambodscha innovativ zu gestalten
es besteht immer das Risiko manche
abzuhängen wenn wir aber gemeinsame
Ziele setzen können wir ein inklusiveres
Wachstum für alle erreichen
wir sollten nicht vergessen wenn die
Flut kommt hebt sie alle Boote
gleichermaßen darum müssen wir einander
helfen
niemand weiß wie Asia an in 10 20 oder
50 Jahren aussehen wird ein solides
Fundament schafft jedoch eine gute
Perspektive nun ist es an der
Staatsführung den nächsten Schritt zu
wagen das spiegeln die aktuelle Führung
Südostasiens die Ambitionen der nächsten
Generation wieder
[Musik]
nein
die Politiker sind nach wie vor
durchschnittlich 70 Jahre alt die Bürger
im Schnitt 29
ich bewundere ihre Leistungen der
Vergangenheit von ganzem Herzen aber es
gibt viele Probleme die sie nicht
angehen
sozialgerechte Bildung jeder sieht
Gerechtigkeit und Bildung anders
the way es geht darum wie wir unsere
Geld verdienen
ich habe die Regierungen Malaysia schon
öfter gesagt sie sollen in die
Technologiebranche investieren um mehr
Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen als Sie sich
vorstellen können
[Musik]
am Fortschritt von Asien besteht kein
Zweifel
das durchschnittliche
Wirtschaftswachstum aller zehn Länder
liegt seit zehn Jahren jedes Jahr bei
fünf Prozent
die verbraucherschicht wächst es gibt
bessere Löhne mehr Arbeitsplätze und
mehr Infrastruktur auch der
Online-Handel ist trotz bescheidener
Anfänge im Höhenflug
meine Vision für südostasien ist recht
bodenständig
großartige in Natur und Software
großartige Regularien und politische
Systeme
Korruption und Bestechung vollkommen aus
und richten bessere Staatsführung mit
mehr Rechenschaft für Menschen und alle
Beteiligten ein
Halloween
uns vom politischen Ränkespielen und
persönlicher Ideologie
die Zahlen werden uns bestätigen in 10
20 Jahren wird die Wirtschaft von Asien
13 Billionen US-Dollar erreichen
das entspricht der Wirtschaftsleistung
von Großbritannien Frankreich und
Deutschland zusammen
so mit derartiger Größe kommt das
Selbstvertrauen
wir hoffen dass Indonesien dass heute 40
Prozent davon ausmacht entsprechend
mitwachsen kann
in den nächsten 10 15 Jahren werden wir
sehen wie die Jugend sich auch über die
Grenzen Südostasiens hinweg durchsetzen
wird und wie sich hier viel mehr
Start-ups etablieren werden
ihr Traum für Asian in zehn Jahren
ein geeinter Markt wäre großartig Asien
muss sich selbst als gewaltigen Markt
erkennen Einigkeit ist immer wichtig und
ich würde gerne einen geeinten Markt
entstehen sehen
ich hätte gerne eine Vielzahl an Firmen
die sich durch ganz Asien bewegen und
Asia nicht nur als geeinten Markt
sondern auch als geeinte Bevölkerung
sehen
[Musik]
bei Inklusion Nachhaltigkeit und
Vernetzung könnte sich der endspur
jedoch als die größte Herausforderung
erweisen
gemeinsamen Probleme zu lösen sind alle
leidenschaftlich dabei
die Armut die Sanitärversorgung die
Ausweitung des Einzelhandels in
bestimmten Regionen
die Einrichtung von fintech damit das
Finanzwesen günstiger wird und Darlehen
pünktlich bezahlt werden können
wir alle müssen die gleichen Hindernisse
überwinden und die gleichen Probleme
lösen
wir alle ein Volk haben aber auch unsere
Eigenheiten
[Musik]
es geht um uns und unser Erbe bist du
unsere Eltern oder Großeltern
zu viele haben kein Bankkonto der
aktuelle Finanzmarkt lässt zu viele
Probleme umgelöst
wie können wir das aus der Perspektive
der jüngeren Bewohner Südostasiens lösen
das Durchschnittsalter in Südostasien
ist 29 Jahre wenn wir sind Südostasien
nicht die über 60-Jährigen Politiker
wir sind die kommende Generation
die Zukunft Asians ist hier und sie ruht
auf den Schultern einer jungen
Generation der sich dann schneller
Veränderung eine einmalige Chance bietet
danke für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit bei Asian
the next generation
[Musik]